WHEN YOU HAVE JUST HEARD IS THE
GAVEL OF DEMOCRACY IN THE
SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE AND THE
RULE OF LAW. THE TO DEMOCRACY
AND THE RULE OF LAW ARE
INSEPARABLE. LET US BE A
SHINING EXAMPLE TODAY THAT WILL
MAKE OUR CHILDREN PROUD. IN OUR
DEMOCRACY STRENGTHENED.
ELECTORS AND GUESTS ESPRESSO
FILED BY FEDERAL LAW TODAY
MONDAY DECEMBER FOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY. IS THE FIRST
MONDAY AFTER THE SECOND
WEDNESDAY IN DECEMBER IN THE
HOUR OF TWO PM HAVING ARRIVED
THE PROCEEDINGS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTORAL COLLEGE
FOR THE SELECTION OF THE
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES. ARE NOW IN
ORDER MY NAME IS KEVIN MULLIN
ON THE SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY. THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE IS FORMED
EVERY FOUR YEARS FOR THE SOLE
PURPOSE OF FORMALLY ELECTING
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AS REQUIRED BY THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. WE WELCOME YOU TO THE
CHAMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE CAPITOL FOR
THIS PURPOSE. I WOULD
PERSONALLY LIKE TO THANK
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY SPEAKER
ANTHONY RENDON FOR DESIGNATING
ME TO CONVENE OUR HISTORIC
PROCEEDINGS TODAY. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE STAFF
HERE IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY AS WELL THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY. FOR MAKING ALL THE NEXT
NECESSARY ARRANGEMENTS TO MAKE
TODAY'S SESSION A SUCCESS. AND
COMPLIANT WITH CONSTITUTIONAL
REQUIREMENTS. AS WELL AS OUR
SERGEANT AT ARMS FOR ENSURING A
SMOOTH SESSION TODAY. WE TOO
WOULD LIKE TO WALK OF THE
VIEWERS OF CASE HERE KCRA TV
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AS WELL AS-
VIEWERS OF C. SPAN AND OTHER
MEDIA OUTLETS. FROM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WHO ARE FOLLOWING THESE
PROCEEDINGS TODAY. CALIFORNIA
THE MOST POPULOUS STATE IN THE
UNITED STATES WILL BE FORMALLY
CASTING ITS VOTES. FOR THE
WINNER OF OUR STATE POPULAR
VOTE. JOSEPH R. BIDEN AND VICE
PRESIDENTIAL RUNNING MATE
CALIFORNIA'S OWN KAMILLA
HARRIS. TODAY'S PROCEEDING IN
THIS CHAMBER HAS ADDED
HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE AS IT
IS EXPECTED THAT WOULD
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY FIVE
ELECTORAL VOTES ARE CAST.
JOSEPH R. BIDEN WILL IMPROPERLY
SECURED MORE THAN THE REQUISITE
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
ELECTORAL VOTES TO FORMALLY BE
ELECTED PRESIDENT. OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. WE
ASK AT THIS TIME THAT ARE
ELECTOR DESIGNATES AND STAFF IN
THE CHAMBER PLEASE STAND. AND
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE. KATE WILLIAMS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR THE
PLEDGE IS WHITE. PLEASE PLACE
YOUR RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR HEART
READY BEGIN. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. AND
TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU MAY
BE SEATED. THE FIRST ORDER OF
BUSINESS IS THE ROLL CALL OF
THE ELECTORS AS THIS UNFOLDS
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING AS YOU
HEAR YOUR NAME CALLED. IN UNTIL
THE NAMES OF ALL FIFTY FIVE
ELECTORS HAVE BEEN CALLED THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL. BRIAN
SU LEGI. THOMAS MACHEN ERNIE.
ELIZABETH CAN. CARA BENSEL.
MARY BELKHIR. N. SAYING- JANINE
BERRA. CATHERINE BANCROFT.
GILLIAN MCNERNEY. DONNA KIRK
LEAD VARUN. JANE PENTEL. MATTIE
SCOTT. LINNEY'S JONES. PAUL
MCCLOSKEY. FREDDIE DAVIS.
MARCIA COLONUS. AMY ROW. DAVID
KENNEDY. KATHARINE WILKINSON.
VINCENNES KOHLER. STEVEN DIVERT.
PATTY CAPULETI. BROCK NEARLY.
MATALIN HANDY. BRANDON'S OF
ALLAH. FRANKLIN LIMA. NAOMI
TOMITA. WALLACE KNOCKS. RONALD
HERRERA. WILLIAM BRADY.
CRISTINA MARQUIS. ANDRE QUINN
TERO. J. HE WHO A. MARK
GONZALEZ. ROBERT TORRES.
AUGUSTINE AREA OLA. YOU'LL
LANDA PARKER. CATHERINE BOARD.
JACKIE CISNEROS. VERY AT
MINERAL OI. SUZANNE SINGER.
BRANDON BENJAMIN. KAREN WATERS.
EMILY DREAD. LEE THANK. MELITA
MENDOZA. ALEX NORMAN. AARON
STURTEVANT. KEVIN SUB ILLEGAL.
PETER BOLAND. SHIRLEY WEBER.
JANICE BROWN. BRIAN FLETCHER.
ROSALIND WYMAN. TATE WILLIAMS.
I WILL BE ADMINISTERING THE
OATH OF OFFICE SIMULTANEOUSLY
TO ALL ELECTOR DESIGNATES MASS
ALL ELECTORS TO RAISE THEIR
RIGHT HANDS FOR THE OATH OF
OFFICE OF ELECTOR FOR PRESIDENT
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. FOR THE
OFFICE OF A LETTER FOR
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
PLEASE RAISE YOUR RIGHT HAND.
DO YOU SOLEMNLY SWEAR THAT YOU
WILL SUPPORT AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES AND THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AGAINST
ALL ENEMIES. FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC THAT YOU WILL BEAR
TRUE FAITH AND ALLEGIANCE TO
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES. AND THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT
YOU TAKE THIS OBLIGATION FREELY
WITHOUT ANY MENTAL RESERVATION
OR PURPOSE OF EVASION AND THAT
YOU WILL WELL AND FAITHFULLY
DISCHARGE THE DUTIES. UPON
WHICH YOU'RE ABOUT TO ENTER IF
SO PLEASE CONFIRM YOUR- BY
STATING I DO. CONGRATULATIONS
YOU MAY BE SEATED. THERE IS AN
OPEN DISTRIBUTED AT YOUR DESK
THAT IS TO BE SIGNED WHERE
INDICATED.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
NOMINATIONS FOR THE OFFICE OF
CHAIRPERSON OF CALIFORNIA'S
ELECTORAL COLLEGE FOR THE
SELECTION OF PRESIDENT AND VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THE NOMINATIONS ARE NOW OPEN.
B. MARK GONZALES OF
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT THIRTY
FOUR IS RECOGNIZED FOR THE
PURPOSE OF NOMINATION MR
GONZALEZ. GOOD AFTERNOON A
LECTORS AND FRIENDS MY NAME IS
MARK AND DOLPHIN I PROBABLY
REPRESENT THE THIRTY FOURTH
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT AND I AM
PLEASED TO NOMINATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SHIRLEY WEBER AS
CHAIRPERSON FOR CALIFORNIA'S
ELECTORAL COLLEGE. TWENTY
TWENTY. THIS NOMINATION
REQUIRES A SECOND. KEVIN
SABELLA CAL OF CD FORTY NINE IS
RECOGNIZED TO SECOND THE
NOMINATION OF MR GONZALEZ MR
SABBATICAL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I AM HAVEN'T DEVELOPED
GO OF CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT
FORTY NINE AND I SECOND THE
NOMINATION OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHIRLEY WEBER AS CHAIRPERSON
FOR CALIFORNIA'S ELECTORAL
COLLEGE. FOR TWENTY TWENTY. ARE
THERE ANY FURTHER NOMINATIONS
FOR THE OFFICE OF CHAIR OF THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE OF TWENTY
TWENTY. SENATE HEARING NINE
NOMINATIONS FOR THE OFFICE OF
CHAIR OF THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE
OF TWENTY TWENTY ARE NOW
CLOSED. WE WILL MOVE TO A VOICE
VOTE TO ELECT THE CHAIR OF THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO A VOICE VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO
OBJECTIONS ALL IN FAVOR OF
ELECTING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHIRLEY WEBER AS THE
CHAIRPERSON OF THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE SAY HI. OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SHIRLEY WEBER
CONGRATULATIONS YOU ARE ELECTED
CHAIRPERSON OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTORAL COLLEGE FOR THE
SELECTION OF THE PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. PLEASE COME
TO THE ROSTRUM ELECTRICITY GAS
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
THE CHAIRPERSON OF THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTORAL COLLEGE
FOR THE SELECTION OF THE
PRESIDENT OR VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND MY
GREAT COLLEAGUE SHIRLEY WEBER.
THANK YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN AND THANKS TO ALL OF YOU
WHO ARE DIRECTORS. HAVING
SELECTED ME AS CHAIR OF
ELECTORAL COLLEGE. I THINK ALL
OF US REALIZE JUST HOW
SIGNIFICANT THIS EXPERIENCE IS.
MOST OF YOU LIKE ME READ ABOUT
IT WHEN YOU'RE A KID IN SCHOOL
NEVER KNEW WHAT THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE WAS THAT IT WAS SOME
BUILDING SOMEWHERE THAT MAYBE
PEOPLE WENT TO SCHOOL IN. BUT
WE LEARNED OVER TIME THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
CONSTITUTION. IT'S AN IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR PROCESS THE ORDERLY
PROCESS OF THE TRANSFERRED TO
POWER. BUT IT'S ALSO A PART OF
OUR REPRESENTATION. MAKING SURE
THAT EVERY PERSON. WHO VOTED IN
CALIFORNIA WHO VOTED THIS
NATION HAVE THE RIGHT TO HAVE
THEIR VOTE COUNT. AND TO BE
REPRESENTED BY THE LEAD TO A
COLLEGE. IF YOU TRAVEL AROUND
THE WORLD YOU HAVE SEEN THE
TRAGEDIES THAT OCCUR WHEN YOU
DON'T HAVE AN ORDERLY
TRANSFERENCE OF POWER. AND WE
ARE PROUD OF THE FACT THAT IN
THIS NATION WE HAVE ALWAYS HAD
AN ORDERLY TRANSFER THE POWER.
AND DESPITE WHAT WE MAY THINK
WE SEE OUTSIDE IT IS HERE TODAY.
AND THAT IS WHAT WE'RE DOING
REPRESENTING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. I'M HONORED THAT
YOU ASKED ME TO CHEER THIS. IS
A CHILD WHO'S A PARENT OF
SHARECROPPERS WHOSE
GRANDPARENTS NEVER GOT A CHANCE
TO VOTE HOPE ARKANSAS. I'M SURE
THEY'RE BEAMING DOWN REALIZING
THAT THEIR DAUGHTER THEIR
GRANDDAUGHTER IS AN ELECTORAL.
BUT NOT ONLY JUST ELECTED WITH
THE CHAIR OF THE COLLEGE THAT
IS GOING TO COMPLETE THE
BUSINESS WE BEGAN ON NOVEMBER
THIRD. SO ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH FOR YOUR FAITH AND
CONFIDENCE AND PARTICIPATION IN
THIS PROCESS. EVERY BEGIN THERE
ARE SIX ELECTORS THAT WE ARE
UNABLE THEY WERE UNABLE TO BE
HERE TODAY. AND TO FILL THOSE
VACANCIES WE HAVE A NOMINATION
A VOTE AND AN ADMINISTRATION OF
THE OATH OF OFFICE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION I'M REQUESTING THE
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO FILL ALL
THE VACANCIES AT ONE TIME. THIS
MOTION REQUIRES A SECOND. IN
THE END- AND SO THEREFORE I'M
ASKING FOR THE MOTION TO
BASICALLY. DOMINATE THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HERE THE
NOMINATIONS OPEN FOR
REPLACEMENT. OF ELECTED TO FILL
THE VACANCIES FOR THE SECOND
WELL THESE CONGRATS SEVERAL
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICTS. AND
SEE VACANCY AND SENATE
VACANCIES THAT WE SEE. CD
TWENTY ONE CD THIRTY SEVEN CD
FORTY SEVEN CD TWENTY EIGHT AND
THIRTY EIGHT. AND THE SENATE
SEATS UP FOR SENATOR FEINSTEIN
NEEDS TO BE FILLED THEIR SIX
VACANCIES. IS THERE A MOTION.
ON THE FLOOR. OKAY YES. WE'VE
GOT. MANAGED CARE I MET THIS
GUY IN I NOMINATE JOSEPH ****
RUSTY JOINT. EVENT MORE JOHN
CASE. AND AEROSPACE TIME TO
FILL THE VOID. FOR PROGRESSION
OF THIS. 212-837-3840 SEVEN AND
ONE SENATE APPOINTMENT. THERE'S
A REQUEST FOR A SECOND. MR
JACKIE WHO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MY NAME IS JEAN KERR AND
I SECOND THE NOMINATION OF THE
REPLACEMENT OF LECTORS JOSEPH
**** RESTING HER YOUR ACTIONS
AND YOU GET MARTINE. JOHN AND
GERALD. TO FILL VACANCIES FOR
THE COMMUTER THE- CITY. ONE
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY SEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT FORTY SEVEN AND
THE ONE SENATE APPOINTMENT
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY FURTHER NOMINATIONS.
HEARING AND SEEING ON THE
NOMINATIONS FOR REPLACEMENT
ELECTORS ARE NOW CLOSED. WE'LL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
APPOINTMENT OF REPLACEMENT
LEXUS TO FILL THE VACANCIES IS
THERE AN OBJECTION TO A VOICE
VOTE. SINGLE OBJECTIONS ALL OF
THESE ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF
APPOINTING JOSEPH PATRICK ****
RUSTY HICKS JOYS AT JOY
ATKINSON. YVETTE MARTINEZ JOHN
CASEY IN DARRELL STEINBERG TO
FILL THE VACANCY. BEING
SPECIFIED BY SAYING. HI-
ALTHOUGH THE PO SAY NAY. THE
EYES HAVE IT IN THERE FOR YOU-
JOSEPH **** RUSTY. JOINT EVENT
MARCH JOHN K. IN THE- FIND
BURKE ARE POINTED TO FILL THE
VACANT. ELECTORS DOESN'T NOW
SHE STAND. AT THEIR DESK. AND
ASSEMBLY MULLINS WILL NOW
ADMINISTER THE OATH OF OFFICE.
THANK YOU. FOR THE OFFICE OF A
LECTURE FOR PRESIDENT VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA PLEASE RAISE YOUR
RIGHT HAND. DO YOU SOLEMNLY
SWEAR THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT AND
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES. AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AGAINST ALL ENEMIES.
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC THAT YOU
WILL BEAR TRUE FAITH AND
ALLEGIANCE TO THE CONSTITUTION
OF THE UNITED STATES AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT YOU TAKE THIS
OBLIGATION FREELY WITHOUT ANY
MENTAL RESERVATION OR PURPOSE
OF EVASION AND THAT YOU WILL
WELL AND FAITHFULLY DISCHARGE
THE DUTIES UPON WHICH YOU'RE
ABOUT TO ENTER. IF SO PLEASE
AFFIRM YOUR OATH BY STATING I
DO. CONGRATULATIONS.
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
FOR ACCEPTING THAT
RESPONSIBILITY- YOU MAY BE
SEATED AS YOU HAVE A COPY OF
THE OLD IS ON YOUR DESK PLEASE
SIGN IN PRINTER NAMED WHERE
INDICATED AND LEAVE IT ON YOUR
DESK THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M
APPOINTING NINE TELLERS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTORAL COLLEGE
WITH TWENTY TWENTY THERE SEATED
THROUGHOUT THE CHAMBER AND SO
CONGRATULATIONS TO BOTH OF YOU
ON YOUR DESIGNATION AS A TELLER.
WE WILL NOT UNDERTAKE THE
IMPORTANT TASK OF VOTING. ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
ELECTORS YOU WILL FIND A BLUE
BALLOT FOR PRESIDENT ON YOUR
DESK. PLEASE ASSIGN THE BALLOT
WERE INDICATED.
UHHUH. OTHER.
CONTROL WE HAVE- YOU NEED TO
HOLD UP ON THE FOR JUST A
SECOND WE'RE GOING TO DO THAT
WE'RE GOING TO COLLECT THOSE
BALLOTS BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
SELECT A SECRETARY. AT THIS
TIME- YEAH. YEAH WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND PASS THE TELLERS TO
COLLECT THE BALLOTS AND ONCE WE
HAVE COLLECTED THE BALLOTS TO
HOLD THE BALANCE WHAT WE SELECT
THE SECRETARY. SUMMER WEBER.
YES MY NAME IS MARK GONZALEZ
I'M PROBABLY REPRESENTING THE
THIRTY FOURTH CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT. AD I NOMINATE
FRANKLIN LIMA A SECRETARY OF
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTORAL COLLEGE
TWENTY TWENTY. THEIR SECOND TO
THE NOMINATION OF SECRETARY.
MADAM CHAIR I AM HAVEN'T
DEVELOPED A OF THIRTY FORTY
NINE AND I SECOND THE
NOMINATION OF FRANKLIN LIMA AS
SECRETARY OF CALIFORNIA'S
ELECTORAL COLLEGE FOR TWENTY
TWENTY FOR THE ANY ADDITIONAL
NOMINATIONS FOR SECRETARY.
HEARING AND SEEING THE WE WILL
NOT TAKE A VOICE VOTE IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO DOING A VOICE
VOTE. SEEING OBJECTION TO THAT
WE WILL NOW VOTE FOR MR LIMA
FOR SECRETARY ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. THOSE OPPOSED
SAY NAY. CONGRATULATIONS MISTER
LIMA YOU ARE NOT SECRETARY OF
THE- LIKE FOR COLLEGE PLEASE
CLICK THE BALLOT STELLAR AND
BRING THEM TO MOVE FROM.
THANK
YOU SECRETARY LIMA I WILL NOW
NINTH THE TO ANNOUNCE THE TALLY
OF THE VOTES FOR THE OFFICE OF
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
FOR JOSEPH R. BIDEN OF
DELAWARE. THE DEMOCRATS. I
FIFTY FIVE NOES.
ZERO NOW WE
WILL UNDERTAKE THE VOTE FOR
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES ELECTORS YOU WILL FIND
THE RED BALLOT FOR VICE
PRESIDENT ON YOUR DESK. PLEASE
THE BALLOT WERE INDICATED.
TELLERS PLEASE COLLECT THE
BALANCE.
ALL.
I WILL NOW
ANNOUNCE THE TALLY FOR THE
VOTES FOR THE OFFICE OF VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
BUT SENATOR COMEDY HERIS OF
CALIFORNIA. A DEMOCRAT I FIFTY
FIVE KNOWS ZERO.
YES OUR NEXT
ORDER OF BUSINESS IS THE
SIGNING OF OFFICIAL DOCUMENTS.
PLEASE REMAIN IN YOUR ON YOUR
DESK WHILE THE TELLERS
COLLECTIVE DITIONS SIGNATURES
FROM YOU AND REVIEW THE
DOCUMENTS FOR COMPLETENESS THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT PART OF THE
PROCESS. THIS PROCESS MAY TAKE
UP TO THIRTY MINUTES. PLEASE
REMAIN SOCIALLY DISTANCE DURING
THE REQUIRED WITHIN THIS
REQUIREMENT AND DO NOT LEAVE
YOUR SEAT. WE WILL LET YOU KNOW
WHEN WE ARE DISMISSED THIS IS
AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT PROCESS
SO DO NOT LEAVE UNTIL WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY FINISHED AND WE ARE
DISMISSED AT THIS TIME WE WILL
COMPLETE THE TELLERS WILL WORK
WITH YOU ON THE DOCUMENTS THAT
YOU NEED TO SIGN. OFFICIALLY
SIGNED TO MAKE THIS THIS
EXPERIENCE WE'VE HAD TODAY THE
SIX IMPORTANT PART OF
DEMOCRACY. OFFICIALS.
YEAH.
ALL.
YOUR.
YEAH.
RIGHT.
ONE YEAH.
YEAH.
ELECTORS.
I'M SURE YOU ALL REALIZE JUST
HOW IMPORTANT THIS DAIS. AND
YOUR ROLE IN MAKING IT VERY
SPECIAL. SOME OF YOU WERE WITH
ME FOUR YEARS AGO. WHEN WE CAST
OUR BALLOTS. AND WE DIDN'T GET
THE SAME RESULTS NATIONALLY.
BUT NONETHELESS WE WERE HERE.
WE DID OUR TASK WE REPRESENTED
THE INTERESTS OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE DID OUR DUTY.
THERE'S ALWAYS A LONG JOURNEY
FROM ONE ELECTION TO THE NEXT.
AND SOMETIMES IT'S MORE SPECIAL
THAN OTHERS BUT NONE THE LESS
IT ALWAYS IS A REFLECTION OF
WHO WE ARE AS A PEOPLE. AND HOW
WE MOVE FORWARD AND HOW WE
REGROUP AND HOW WE CONTINUE TO
HOLD FAST TO THE VALUES AND THE
PRINCIPLES THAT WE SO STRONGLY
BELIEVE IN. AND YOU HAVE DONE
THAT TODAY. WE'VE MADE ALL OF
THOSE WHO STAND SO FIRM ON THIS
CONSTITUTION VERY PROUD.
BECAUSE WE HAVE ENSURED THAT
THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE WILL BE
DONE. I JUST THINK HOW AMAZING
IT'S BEEN IN FOR YEARS. YES
WE'VE HAD OUR CHALLENGES I WAS
REMINDED TODAY THAT THIS IS THE
EIGHTH ANNIVERSARY OF SANDY
HOOK. THAT EIGHT YEARS AGO WE
LOST A LOT OF CHILDREN IN THIS
NATION. AND YET WE'VE CONTINUED
AS A NATION TO MOVE FORWARD.
WE'VE NEVER ALLOWED ONE CRISIS
ONE EVENT ONE MISHAP ONE
MISSTEP. TAKE US DOWN. AND EVEN
THOUGH WE STRUGGLE WITH WHO WE
ARE AND WHERE WE ARE AND WHAT
WE VALUE. WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD AS A NATION. AND WE
CONTINUE TO VALIDATE THIS
ENTERPRISE CALLED DEMOCRACY.
AND WE ARE MOST IMPERFECT UNION
CONSOLATION TROUBLING TO BECOME
PERFECT. AND AS LONG AS WE HAVE
THAT AS OUR VALUE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD. WE'VE
DONE OUR TASK YOU TODAY. WE
HAVE COMPLETED OUR BUSINESSES
CALIFORNIA ELECTORS AND WE HAVE
SELECTED CALIFORNIA'S CHOICE
FOR PRESIDENT AND VICE
PRESIDENT. WE TODAY THE
ELECTORS OF CAST FIFTY FIVE
VOTES MORE THAN ANY OTHER STATE.
FOR JOE BIDEN AS PRESIDENT AND
FIFTY FIVE VOTES THE COMELEC
HARRIS IS VICE PRESIDENT.
EACH
ONE OF US CAN RETURN TO OUR
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICTS. AND TO
OUR SENATORS AND LET THEM KNOW
THAT WE HAVE DONE AND DONE WELL.
THAT WE HAVE COMPLETED OUR TASK.
SO ON BEHALF OF ALL THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA I WANT TO THANK
YOU. NOT ONLY FOR THIS
GENERATION BUT FOR GENERATIONS
TO COME. DID WE CONTINUE TO
VALIDATE. THAT THIS DEMOCRACY.
THIS EXPERIMENT. INCLUDING
TREATING EVERYONE EQUAL. AND
MAKING SURE THAT EVERY VOTE
COUNTS. IS TRULY TRULY
SUCCESSFUL AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO HOLD FAST TO VALUES OF THIS
NATION. WITH THAT BEING SAID
I'M REALLY READY TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION FOR ADJOURNMENT MR
GONZALEZ. SURE MR SIMPSON BELKO
PLEASE SECOND IT I SECOND THE
MOTION TO ADJOURN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SIGNIFY BY SAYING AYE. ALL
THOSE OPPOSE YOU JUST DON'T
WANT TO GO HOME IS THANK YOU
AND HAVE A PARTY. ALL THOSE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. BELIEVE IT OR
NOT WE'RE GERMAN THANK YOU.
PLEASE LEAVE YOUR OLD ON THE
DESK IF THEY HAVE NOT TURNED
THE MAN AND THE STAFF WILL PICK
THEM UP THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.